[Music]
[Applause]
hello my friends i'm matt welcome back
to my kitchen for the past several
months i have been learning to cook with
new ingredients from all around the
world first it was maggie noodles from
india which i used to make a fried
chicken sandwich then it was baghwang
from the philippines which i used to
make putnesska now once again i have
been challenged to use an ingredient
from india i'm vishal from buzzfeed
india and matt i'm about to give you the
biggest challenge of your life we
indians love our food do i even need to
tell you that but one fact that's not
very popular about us indians is that we
love our biscuits today i'm about to
tell you about one of our most beloved
parliji biscuits
they started producing in the year 1939
and they never stopped we got
independence in 1947.
i love dipping these biscuits in the tea
and eating it oh it's just best best
experience ever and it's so comforting
matt
today i'm challenging you to make an
original dish using parliaghi as an
ingredient can you do this can you do
this i can do it you have to all right
vishal once again challenge accepted i'm
going to pop over to my favorite indian
grocery store to see if they have these
parley g biscuits
[Music]
there they are parley g biscuits parley
g original gluco cookies i don't know
what a gluco cookie is gluco cookies
okay so gluco cookies just mean it's
slightly sweetened so gluco for i'm
assuming glucose or sugar let's open it
up
oh
it's quite ornate i wasn't expecting it
to be quite so pretty looking
it smells like an animal cracker
it kind of tastes like an animal cracker
too that's good i made myself a nice hot
mug of tea here
oh
very nice all in all these biscuits are
good having it with tea is definitely
the way to go so what i'm going to do is
brainstorm for a little bit try and
think about some ways i can use the
parle g
i've done a bit of brainstorming made my
trip to the store and now it is time to
cook so i actually want to make two
recipes just because parle g is so
simple i want to make it a few different
ways see how i can use it for this first
recipe i'm trying to make cookie butter
i have a food processor here
to which
i am adding
20
partly g biscuits
and
oh
that looks pretty good to me
nice and fine and to this i am adding
evaporated milk
sweetened condensed milk and finally
some cubed butter and this looks like a
lot of butter but it's not meant to be a
healthy recipe so whatever
scrape down the sides cookie butter is
supposed to have a bit of a peanut
butter texture and this looks a little
bit loose and watery for my taste so
let's add
one
two three four
five
that looks pretty good it's very smooth
and creamy let's get that cookie butter
down in my cookie butter jar and there
you have it parley g cookie butter comes
together in like less than 10 minutes
super easy all right moment of truth
whoa honestly this is low-key perfect
it's super creamy super light the flavor
is nice and sweet and a little bit mild
it definitely tastes like the parley g
this is absolutely delicious i would
have this with fruit i would have it on
toast eat it straight up vishal
good luck making this i hope you like it
but i have one more recipe i want to try
using the parleigh g that i think takes
it to the next level my second recipe
involving these biscuits is a parley g
banana cream pie that's a mouthful so my
plan is to use the parley g in the crust
so my plan is to use the parley g in the
crust as well as in the actual pie
itself my handy food processor has
returned to which i am adding
40 partly g biscuits
which hopefully will fit i'm gonna have
to do this in batches
let's see if we can fit the remaining
ones in here and of course if you don't
have a food processor
you can put them in a bag and smash them
with something very therapeutic
and now that this is all nice and
crumpled i am adding my melted butter
scrape that off the sides
to scoop my parlay g right in there and
i'm just going to spread this out in a
pretty even layer measuring cup i'm just
going to use my measuring cup to kind of
press
my parley g
into my pie dish
just gently pressing
sides in
i'm very happy with how this turned out
i kind of want to just run my knife
along the top
this will make everything nice and even
one more good little press
and that is my parleji pie crust i'm
just going to pop this in the oven for
about 10 minutes so it crisps up a
little bit it's nice golden brown to it
it's time to start my banana cream
filling but i want to up the parley g
factor of this pie just a little bit i
have my milk here to which i'm just
going to add
one
two
three so i'm borrowing a technique out
of christina tosi's cookbook much like
she uses cereal to flavor milk for her
different cereal milk ice creams i want
to flavor the milk with parley g so i'm
just going to let these soak up and then
break down so it's a little bit
difficult to tell but there's all these
bits of parlay g just floating around in
my milk it's nice and dissolved pour in
my parley g milk
[Music]
look at that there's a whole bunch of
schmutz at the bottom just gonna scrape
that out
i'm not too worried if there's big
chunks in here because i'm about to beat
all this together and so
it doesn't really matter
to this i'm adding my banana pudding mix
and i am just gonna whisk until it's
nice and combined and it should start to
thicken after a few minutes i also hope
they have banana pudding in india i feel
like it would be banana custard i tried
looking it up to make sure that it was
on sale there and it looked like it but
this could backfire on me let's test to
see this pudding
yeah that's set
honestly i could probably add more
parley g to the milk just a little bit
too late now so
it's fine i have unsweetened whipped
cream which i'm slowly and gradually
going to add to my pudding and i'm going
to fold it in
so i don't crush all of the air out of
it i couldn't actually find unsweetened
whipped cream anywhere so i just took
heavy whipping cream
and mixed it up the guide for me is
about half the amount of heavy whipping
cream to whipped cream so in this case
i'm using about three cups of whipped
cream which was one and a half cups of
heavy whipping cream the remaining third
of my whipped cream
gently fold it in
you can see how much fluffier this has
gotten oh it's like a cloud and there
you go it's not over mixed but it's nice
and fluffy
that is my filling done let's assemble
this pie here it is
the parley g crust for my pie it did
shrink a little bit on the outside but
i'm actually quite happy with it plus
the true mark of a good crust
nice and crispy music to my ears i just
want to line the bottom with a bunch of
sliced banana just to add a little bit
more banana flavor this is about two
bananas sliced
perfect
i'm just going to pop you in there
slowly pour that over the top
i just want to gradually spread all of
my filling out
and there it is my parley g banana cream
pie it's not quite done yet i want to
beautify it a little bit but before i do
i'm going to pop this in the fridge for
a little bit to set i am just going to
add some shredded coconut to the top of
this
and i love love love
coconut
this looks excellent the toasted coconut
really puts it over the top for me i
think it adds a nice color contrast this
looks great but does it taste great
out pops
very
there we have it attempt number two much
better than attempt number one i've got
my parley g butter crust on it there's
that thin layer of bananas on the bottom
we've got our banana cream our banana
pudding on top and then the toasted
coconut to finish it all off
here goes
the parlej biscuits are perfect as the
crust they're nice and crunchy the
texture's really good it's not too sweet
my banana filling is super light and
fluffy with good banana flavor you get
those little banana slices on the bottom
that add like a nice texture to
everything and then the toasted coconut
on top really kind of seals the deal
very happy with this pie it is
absolutely delicious so refreshing it's
a hot day out this is a cool pie i love
it so there we have it the two recipes i
could come up with using parley g the
parliament cookie butter and the carly g
banana cream pie i'm very happy with how
they both turned out but i am not the
judge of them so i'm going to send these
recipes to vishal and see what he thinks
thank you when i first read through this
recipe i realized that oh my god i'll
have to be baking indians don't really
bake that much many families also don't
even have an oven in their house because
they don't feel the need to it's not
something i do very easily i only
started using an oven
last year and the only thing i have
baked till date is a banana bread so
yes i baked today and i am really proud
of it all right i'm gonna start with the
cookie butter it's like peanut butter
but you make it out of biscuits i have
it here it literally looks like peanut
butter to me okay let's do this
absolutely amazing i mean wow the taste
is very very wholesome it's like the hug
of parliji okay for the cookie butter i
am definitely definitely giving it a
pass time for the next one
[Laughter]
i don't know if my pie and your pie
looks the same mr matthew but i think i
am kind of impressed with myself
[Music]
oh my god
wow
when you're biting it you're getting
some part of the cream and that crispy
biscuit crunch it is absolutely amazing
the parliament banana cream pie is also
getting a pass for me would you try this
recipe at home please let us know in the
comment section down below what did you
think and if you want to catch me and my
friends on a regular basis don't forget
to subscribe to buzzfeed india oh yes
[Music]
[Music]
you